our lauren zima had a chance to sit down
with robert englund the man who brought
Freddie to light as we celebrate that
movies 35th anniversary do people call
you Freddie when they meet you I get
that a lot I get I get you know hey
Freddie yo Freddie at a stoplight a lot
of that mr. Krueger to you super-scary
Robert Englund would play Freddy Krueger
in seven more films after the original
in 1984 turning the horror movie villain
into a pop-culture icon the film was
also the big-screen debut for one future
a list actor by the way we got a clip of
young Johnny Depp here give me your full
name and correct spelling first my name
is Johnny Depp de double P a look at him
he's such a baby face yeah he was the
most polite young actor I'd ever worked
with would you see that his death scene
but certainly one of the classic kills
in the nightmare vernacular also a
classic this house located in LA it
would be the site of Freddy's reign of
terror alright we're walking up to the
house it looks the same I'm wary of
those little girls with a jump rope
singing that song one two Freddy's
coming for
do you get transported back a little bit
to those late nights of shooting there
was an incredible stunt we did within
one of the nightmares the girl Nancy
Heather Langenkamp they had her stunt
double it's upstairs on that side come
out of the window look at this it took
England for hours to transform into
Freddy we were with him back in 1985
during one of those famous makeup
sessions you know there's so many
special effects in in a horror film
and you kind of got to get the jokes out
because you've got you know you've got
tubes going up through your pant leg and
up your bum and out the sides and and
there's blood squirting and I'm wearing
goat bladders under my latex makeup to
make my head expand and and it's kind of
ridiculous because it is the time of
reboots who would you choose them to
play the new Freddy I heard that there
were some discussion of Kevin Bacon I've
heard this rumor I don't know how true
it is but I think that would be an
interesting choice
[Music]